[Applause]
i don't know if they've mentioned this
uh i was recently on black entertainment
television i
kind of have a feeling most you haven't
seen that uh
i don't know why man
last week i went to the movies you know
what movie i had a problem with
the batman movie you guys know this
batman never fights crime in
neighborhoods
that need it
i mean i would love to see batman fight
crime in my neighborhood
i can see and i just robin
yes batman
then we park the car right here man
tell you man growing up in d.c
thinks he's a crazy place to grow i had
like the most dangerous job
in the district of columbia i used to
deliver pizzas for dominoes
they would rob me every day i had to get
a gun man
ever seen a domino's pizza boy the gun
i used to bust in people's apartments
just bombing those freeze
[Music]
put them in the floor man get on your
board don't move
all right i guess when you're banned
like that you get a reputation man i had
like a lot of little friends
my two best friends we're still friends
to this day
two white guys real good guys i took
them to the movies in harlem
about a month ago to see a spike lee
movie they were in shock
miles were hanging open the entire film
these guys had no idea that black people
liked to talk at the movies
i wasn't saying a word you know
everybody else was talking
halfway through the film they look at me
like it was my fault
you know that look they give you oh god
[Laughter]
can't you do something
like i'm gonna stand up brothers
brothers please
[Laughter]
can't you see we have visitors
i just got back from england i had a
hard time
fitting in you know so i tried to make
myself feel comfortable
hang out in the black community you know
but both of those brothers were having a
hard time fitting into
all three of us were roughing it
together
if you ever been to england if you go
through airport security they're real
tense
everyone was real nervous because of
terrorist attacks
everybody except for me
you know why i wasn't scared
because terrorists have never taken
black hostages
and do you know why they have never
taken black hostages
because we are bad bargaining chips
they would call up the white house hello
we have got five black people and we
will kill them
hello hello
can you imagine what kind of world it
would be if people just said whatever
they wanted to
racially i mean like you'd be walking up
the street and a black guy coming to you
hello your white devil
you're rapist of africa why
hello my big lip spear chucking friend
excuse me one second i'm getting kind of
thirsty i think i'll go to the korean
store and get something to drink
hello you slanted at ruining the economy
in our neighborhood by opening stores
and taking the money out to community
check
why hello y'all browse around but never
buy anything suspicious looking like ah
you know
they really go crazy with those with
those little racial stereotypes
i think this is probably the craziest
stereotype any of you will ever hear
and this is true when i was little
i honestly used to believe that all
white people
were happy
just to be white i thought you guys
stood around [ __ ] hey
i'm white i'm king of a hill
top of the heap ray number one
taxi just checking
[Applause]
like ed mentioned i am originally from
dc man uh
all right got some people from dc good
to see you alive folks
let me tell you something that is a
dangerous city man
people ain't a whole bunch of crazy
stuff this guy in my neighborhood named
curtis
used to walk back and forth on my block
just complain about stuff all day
just you know damn
i take curtis man what's wrong man
everyone think i'm a drug dealer just
cause i got a people
i had to explain why it's a courtesy
gotta understand you know
six is kinda young to have a beeper
don't you think
oh man
well i'm glad you guys are clapping
about that cause curtis got real mad at
me
he was gotten his car drove off it was a
nightmare man
i know i was a bad kid myself man but
they turned me around
they sent me to this program called
scared straight
and that's where they send bad kids like
me to prison
and all the prisoners yelling at us you
know try to scare us into being good
i was just heckling them shut up you're
convicted
it's like i'ma take advice from you
oh yeah you look like a person that made
all the right choices in life
i mean no no you know
i don't want you guys to think i'm like
a bad guy the only reason i said that is
because i knew they wouldn't touch me
until they did god grabbed me by my
throat huh
listen here boy i'mma tell you that
if you come to prison you will be
my woman
that worked too
i was in new york city three years ago
no nice welcomes
i got the bus at the port authority i
was all happy i said oh
new york city at last
[Music]
dang this whole bus station stinks
nah it'll probably clear up when i get
outside
every two blocks i smell something i
never smelled before in my life
nobody told me black people can't catch
cabs in new york
i tried to catch a camera at the port
authority a crowd started forming
everyone just looking at me
he's going to be disappointed by so
naive i just
taxi hmm
must not have seen me taxi
no brooklyn hmm
first time i caught a cable on the first
try it scared the hell out of me
i don't know how to feel about it i just
taxi
uh you better go ahead
thank you guys very much like ed said i
am gonna be appearing in court
it's a crazy store i'm eating dinner at
a restaurant
with my best friend he has a little
argument over the check with the waiter
the next thing we know the owner the
manager
all the employees come out and beat the
crap out
buy in front of him compel
he's suing him for half a million
dollars kaboom
but he'll probably win the case because
the whole
incident was recorded on videotape
yeah now i know what you guys are
probably thinking
you're probably saying man dave that is
amazing no it's not
see that's why me and my buddy dave
always carry a camcorder with us
really
everyone should because you never know
when a kodak moment might
pop up we'll be hanging out and be like
all right dave go ahead i got you you
ready man
go and do it all right just be ready
hey officer
this my booty what come over and do it
uh oh roll them
i you know
sometimes though people can't bring
trouble on themselves
other than that before like have you
gone through a little x-ray thing at the
airport
and said a joke about having a gun don't
do that anymore
i think they're just trying to be funny
man i walked to the thing [ __ ]
cuz i'm sorry sir you have to go back
through
i said oh must have been my pistol
hey i was joking
man he was gonna kill him man pull this
gun out and stick out all that stuff
but my buddy dave had the camera roll
thank you guys very much
[Music]
so
[Music]
you ain't believers i used to live in
ohio for three years
yeah it was a very small town lady four
thousand and five hundred people
my house was the black neighborhood let
me tell you something
we had a great time now early on i used
to get in a lot of trouble i don't know
what it was i got suspended from junior
high school
23 times during february
i was writing one time i got hold of all
my teachers home phone numbers
well i feel bad about it now but at the
time it was hilarious
i started calling in death threats
i called up my english teacher mr
johnson he was all nice on the phone
hello
is this mr johnson
yes it is and who might this be you're a
dead [ __ ] who is this
don't worry about that punk you're gonna
die
unless you change david chappelle's
grades
i don't know how he caught me but
i worked at burger king for three years
man
i didn't work the mic though i worked
the grill it's just
the guy that worked the mic used to
drive me crazy
every time someone ordered something hi
yeah let me have uh
let me have a whopper with cheese sure
whopper with cheese it's like you son of
a [ __ ] i'm right behind you
just turn around and ask me for a waffle
with cheese
it's weird being on t you know the funny
thing about tv now now tell me if this
is just me
or do you guys notice this is it me or
do commercials have
nothing to do with the products nowadays
you know am i right i'm serious
i don't even know what a commercial is
about
until they say at the end anyone's seen
a commercial with the lady with the
black eye she got a black eye and she's
crying and
and she's like i smoke crack and my
husband beats me
then a voice came on and said got milk i
said what the hell does milk have to do
with this
well this is interesting i was in uh i
was in san francisco
over the weekend you know just doing a
gig and uh
my friends live up there they said dave
have you seen the sites i said nah
they said well great let's go see
alcatraz this afternoon
what kind of black man in his right mind
would visit a prison for recreation
i got friends in jail i don't visit i'm
scared of jail i'm scared anything has
to do with jail like police i don't deal
with police not even when i need them
i don't call them my house got robbed
last year i didn't call the police
because you know what's gonna happen
as soon as i open the door they'd be
like oh he's still here
open and shut case
i'm having an artistic dilemma i have
two poems
one poem is older and one poem i
just wrote backstage
which one would you like to hear
wait how many for the old one
how many for the new one
all right so remember if it sucks you
asked for
one night at 3 a.m i went to the corner
store
i forgot why oh that's right i wanted a
bite
i had the munchies because i was high
the store is owned by mr phong and every
day he sees me
he does me wrong he's korean
and i'd never say i hate all korean
people i haven't met all korean people
that hate talks for savages
but even though i don't generalize i do
do percentages and averages
[Applause]
so far i hate one out of five korean
people i've
met so far
so i come in the store
hello mr phong i say
and he just scowls at me and growls at
me
buy something huddy
up
now look i'm not stealing the least
but if you're shopping and you know
someone's watching your shop
that shit'll make you look like a thief
this phone said hey i've been watching
you since you came in the door
buy something now or get out of my store
now i couldn't take it anymore hey hey i
said raising my hand
get your fingers out of my face [ __ ]
[Applause]
principle say hey hey
what make you think of chinese you must
not know what you're saying
you made a mistake brac man mr fong is
korean
now i was wrong i was wrong
i said uh mr fong i'm sorry to offend by
mistaking your race
but you gotta admit if it was a chinese
look-alike contest your ass would place
you're a dead ringer for chinese
but don't be mad at me i didn't mean to
offend you in the least
you know some people say all black
people look alike we call those people
police thank you